Bố nếu gấu trong chiên trình gồm, nhá biết tưởng miệng cai ngung lesi y sá thành tuy trên quan.
Tượng đại bắc sơn và nội, với trang lesi y cuốc gia đình chính quảng trị,
công viên lấy thị dương thành phố Gói Linh.
Chương trình sau sáng rất đường, được xây dựng như một trong trại cảm xúc, xuyên xuất qua ba trường.
Những người chưa bao giờ quất, mạnh lệnh trái tin, chiến dịch năm trong ngày đêm,
và trả lại tên cho các anh khá hoàn trình bàn bệnh chia hơn các anh ngung lesi y và tôn bình
những lực lợi đang ngày đêm từ giận như buộc thiền liên,
nhưng kiếm quy tập sát định dành tính hại có lực xí trên khóc mọi mẹn tục quốc.
Sự kết hợp hai hoa dưới những tất mục người thuật xấu lắng.
Còn những thức viên phóng sự thực tế, chân thực và chân trên rau liều lắng động giữa tình,
đã làm xúc độc hàng chiều khán giả thảo giỏi,
câu trình sau sáng dân đường không chỉ là lời chiên, lỗi với những người đã y sân.
Mạnh gọi là lời nhất là mỗi người về năm nay để chắc ý hưởng giữa gì mà mình,
tức nỗi lý tưởng sống và sĩnh đáng với sự in sân của các kế hệ đi trước.